[Music]
John Cena says he can't live without
Nikki Bella because I can't have you out
of my life
marry the couple split in April but have
sparked reconciliation rumours as of
late do you know are they together they
not together can you speak to it you
know they're working on it
so and I think that's one thing is I
think sometimes people think like okay
it's a breakup so they didn't make a
decision quick you know but now like
everyone you just work on it and now a
new clip from total Bellas
shows us how the two seemingly started
to come back together relationship and
marriage especially is about sacrifice
and I will I won't make that sacrifice
for you I will give you a child yes John
just said he'd start a family with Nikki
I feel like there's so much more I want
to do with you an experience with you
it's just wanting to be a mom and
knowing like you will not be a dad it's
a major change of tune for Cena who had
been adamant he didn't want kids
a major factor in their split I'm trying
to ask all these difficult questions
because I don't know if you're just
upset that you're not gonna be a mom
or you have fallen out of love with me
because it kind of feels like both